ROHIT KAMATH: Hello, and
welcome to the session
on best practices for setting
up disaster recovery for SAP
systems in Google Cloud.
My name is Rohit Kamath,
and in this video,
I would like to tell
you a little bit
about the various options
you have for designing
and architecting a disaster
recovery solution for SAP
applications in Google Cloud.
So let's get started.
First, let's quickly
define disaster
as it relates to cloud.
However unlikely
this event may be,
where an entire geographic
region is considered
unavailable, meaning all
applications in this region
are also considered unavailable.
This could be due to
a natural phenomenon
or an unnatural event.
When such an event occurs, the
business continuity process
is triggered, where necessary
folks in the organization
are contacted and a
decision to failover
all business critical
applications to the disaster
recovery site is initiated.
For this purpose, it is
always recommended to properly
test, plan and update
the business continuity
and disaster recovery plans.
Needless to say, anytime
there's a change to the system
or the landscapes,
these plans will
have to be updated accordingly.
Now let's take a
look at items to be
considered for best practices
to handle disaster recovery.
To failover applications to
the disaster recovery site,
proper setup, planning, testing
and validation are necessary.
In every organization,
various applications
are necessary for
business to function.
For each of these business
critical applications,
certain key metrics, namely
recovery point objective
and recovery time objective,
need to be defined.
Recovery point
objective is the amount
of data loss business
is willing to accept
in the event of a disaster.
Meaning transactions that are
being recorded in the system
during normal business
operations on the primary site
that business is willing to live
without in case of a disaster.
These very transactions will
then need to be either manually
or systematically re-entered
in the system on the DR site.
Recovery time objective
on the other hand,
is the amount of
time business is
willing to wait
for these systems
to be up and running
on the DR site.
It also means it's
the amount of time
the teams have to prepare the
systems prior to handing them
over to the business.
So it's the time taken
to restart your database,
start up your
application servers,
validate to ensure the
systems are up and running
in the right order, validate
connectivity of these systems
to peripheral systems,
validate business data,
and also ensure users
connectivity to the DR site.
Depending on the RTO and RPO
defined for each application,
appropriate solutions can
be chosen and implemented.
In case of a low
RTO and RPO, you
will need to ensure the systems
are able to failover quickly.
And in case of
relaxed RTO and RPO,
an appropriate backup restore
solution may be sufficient.
To begin with, it is recommended
to reserve necessary instances
in the DR region to ensure
you have necessary compute
for you to stand up your
business critical applications.
Second, also have a
proper business continuity
plan that is up to date.
Test and validate
these plans at least
once a year, if not
more frequently.
This ensures the teams involved
know exactly what needs
to be done in the event of a
DR. Depending on the application
and databases involved,
there are several ways
of replicating data and
corresponding application
configuration from primary
site to the DR site.
As an example, if you're using
SAP HANA as the database,
there is built-in replication,
referred to as HSR,
or HANA System
Replication, available that
will help with this process.
This HSR will not only
replicate data in the database,
but will also help with database
configuration and other items.
In case of other traditional
databases, like SAP ASE,
log shipping mechanism can
be used to send data over
to the DR site.
In case of application
servers, you
can use Google Cloud
Storage snapshot that
can help with this process.
Now let's take a look
at some of the tools.
If your landscape
is fairly simple
and only has a handful of
applications to failover,
then you can adopt
native Google Cloud tools
to set up your DR process.
As an example, you can use
persistent disk snapshot
mechanism to create
snapshots and schedule
snapshots to ensure data is
backed up on a regular basis.
And in the event you need
to recover from this,
you can restore from these
snapshots onto the DR site.
In case of larger
databases, you can
either continue to use
built-in database replication
and failover mechanism, or
save database backups to Google
Cloud Storage and
restore from them.
These triggers and failovers
can be scripted in Google Cloud.
In case of complex
landscapes, you
can use partner-provided
solutions
that are available in
Google Cloud Marketplace.
Apart from infrastructure,
you will also
need to ensure your network
is laid out appropriately.
This is also to ensure users are
able to connect to the DR site.
Typically, this is done
by updating your network
alias in the DNS to point
to new DR IP addresses.
Second, you need to
ensure the primary
and DR sites are able
to talk to each other
during normal operations
to perform replication.
This is all made simple
and easy in Google Cloud
via the dedicated high
bandwidth, low latency fiber,
which allows connectivity
between sites without having
to go to the internet
or use an ISP.
Virtual Private Cloud,
or VPC, provides
networking functionality
that can extend
your network around the globe.
You can set up your
network in such a way
that your primary site and
DR sites are in the same VPC.
Or you can also create a sub
network and IP address range
for the DR site.
Another option is also to
place your primary and DR
sites in separate VPCs,
or for that matter,
even in completely
different projects.
That's the true flexibility
that Google Cloud provides
at the network layer, giving
you extensive control of how
you want to design
and lay your network.
In closing, I would like to
say that disaster recovery
planning is very application
and organization-specific.
Proper planning and testing
is paramount to having
a smooth failover in the
event of a DR. Google Cloud
can provide tools and integrate
with applications and databases
for a smooth failover process.
Finally, I would like to
point you to documentation
that you can refer to
for items that I did not
cover today, and also find more
detailed documentation on rest
of the topics.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]